hey this is press to
Walker in the due course of mathematical
history mathematicians eventually came
across equations like x^2 is equal
to1 in order to give an answer they
invented a new number I such that i^2 is
equal to1 or I is equal to the Square <
t of
-1 now mathematicians are never content
just to have a new toy they want to play
with it and experiment So eventually
they wondered what is i to the power of
I equal to if we input this into Wolfram
Alpha we get the interesting result that
we have a real answer it's equal to e to
the power of < /2 which is approximately
equal to
0.208 in fact if you look a little
closer it could be a multivalued
result so why exactly does this happen
how is an imaginary number to an
imaginary power equal to a real number
and what are all these other
values so I looked on YouTube and I will
say that in the English videos I found
on YouTube unfortunately all of the
popular ones I've seen are wrong they
have at least one unjustified
step now they do give the correct answer
but it is getting the right answer with
the wrong method so let me just show you
some examples
let's say you need to simplify these
fractions well 16 / 64 we'll just cancel
out the digit six and we get 1 over 4 26
over 65 will cross out the sixes and get
2 over 5 163 over 326 we can cancel out
these digits and we get the answer of
1/2 you get the idea if we just cancel
out the digits in these fractions we're
going to get the right answer but it is
clearly the wrong method it doesn't work
in general but for these cases it does
give you the right answer everybody
would object to using this method even
though you do get the right answer it is
with the wrong
method so in order to understand this a
little better we go to the complex plane
and say a complex number Z is equal to a
plus b
i we can also write this in polar form R
multiplied e to the I Theta so if we
have a complex number Z here we can
imagine a circle with a radius equal to
R and we have this angle Theta but of
course this is not a unique angle we can
add 2 pi to this angle or any multiple
of 2 pi and we'll end up at exactly the
same spot so this number can also be
written as R * e to^ of I mtip the angle
Theta + 2 pi K this is for K being an
integer now let's say that we have the
number
I so R will be equal to 1 and the angle
Theta will be equal to Pi / 2 or any 2
pi multiple of it so I is equal to e to^
of I * piun / 2 + 2 pi
K so for convenience sake we will just
take the principal value where we have K
is equal to 0 and we get that I is equal
to e to the power of I Pi / 2
so here's a supposed proof of why I ^ of
I is equal to e to Pi / 2 you start out
with I is equal to e to I Pi /
2 you raise both sides to the power of I
now on the right hand side we have e to
the I Pi / 2 raised to some power so you
use the rule that a to the power of B
the term raised to the power of C is
equal to a to the power of BC we
multiply these exponents so we get i^ of
I is equal to e to^ of I mtip I Pi / 2 I
* I is equal to 1 so we get I to^ I is
equal to e^ of piun / 2 so we get the
right answer but in fact between steps
two and three this is a wrong step this
step is actually not justified in the
terms of complex powers and I'm going to
explain why this is the
case so in general this rule a to the
power of B raised to the power of C is
equal to a the^ BC it's usually not
shown with all of the conditions but it
should be some conditions like a is a
positive real number and B and C are
real numbers there are other cases in
which it could work but here's just one
of the standard ways in which it does
work it may not in general work if you
have one of the numbers like C being a
complex
number so what would the number one be
in terms of our complex numbers so we
have a radius that's equal to 1 and we
have an angle that's equal to 2 pi it
could also be zero but let's just take 2
pi so we could write 1 as equal to e to
power of 2 pi I what would negative 1 be
one way to represent it we have a radius
of 1 and we have an angle that's equal
to Pi so1 is equal to e to the power of
Pi
so the number one is of course equal to
1^ of 12 but 1 is equal to e to 2 pi I
so we substitute in for 1 so now we have
e to 2 pi I being raised to the power
of2 now what happens if we apply this
rule of multiplying the exponents we get
that this is equal to e to the power of
2 pi I multiplied 12 which simplifies to
be e to the power of Pi Pi I but e to
the power of Pi I is equal
to1 so we have shown that 1 is equal
to1 so this is the pitfall of just
multiplying these exponents you can end
up with an absurd result this is why it
is not a Justified step in
general so now here's a proof I've also
seen so complex exponentiation can be
defined as Z to ^ of w is equal to e ^ W
* the natural log of Z so I ^ I is equal
to e to the^ of I multipli the natural
log of
I but then I we've shown is equal to e
to the I Pi / 2 so we can substitute in
for
I then we have the natural log of e to X
is equal to X so this cancels out so we
have e to ^ I multiplied I < / 2 I * I
is equal to -1 so we get I to ^ of I is
equal to e to^ of Pi / 2 so we got the
right answer but once again we've used
an unjustified step between 2 and three
this is actually wrong in general for
complex numbers so I'm going to explain
why this is the case so let's take this
rule the natural log of e ^ x is equal
to X this is true for real numbers but
this identity may not always hold when X
is a complex number so let's see what
can go
wrong we've shown that 1 is equal to e
to power of 2 I Pi take the natural log
of both sides the natural log of 1 is
equal to zero and then if we apply the
rule on the right hand side we get this
is equal to 2 I Pi so we've shown that 0
is equal to 2 2 I Pi which is wrong so
between the second and third steps here
we can see we can't use the rule that
the natural log of e to ^ x is equal to
X that's an unjustified step so how are
we supposed to calculate I to ^ of I
with a more careful
analysis so in order to do that let's
look at Z to the power of
w how do we even Define complex
exponentiation
the trick is to rely on the power series
definition of e to the power of Z this
converges for all complex number Z it
also has the nice property that e to the
power of U + V is equal to e to the^ U
multiplied by E to the^ V for all
complex numbers u and v we can then
Define Z to the power of w as e to the^
of w multiplied by the natural logarithm
of Z
but now we have another problem we need
to Define what the complex logarithm of
Z is equal to so what is the complex
logarithm of
Z so let's say we have an equation Z is
equal to e to the power of
w if we solve for w that would be our
value for the natural log of Z so the
natural log of Z will be equal to W so
how can we do that well let's represent
Z in terms of polar form so we pull up
this diagram once again now we're going
to write it in another
way so the radius of the circle is
exactly equal to the absolute value of Z
or the modulus or the norm of
Z we can say that the angle Theta + 2 pi
K is equal to the argument of Z so we
can rewrite this as the absolute value
of Z multiplied by E to the power of I
multipli by the argument of Z so we have
another form of the complex number
Z so we say that this form is equal to e
to the power of w now W is a complex
number which we will write as U plus bi
i u and v are real numbers so we can
split this up as e to the^ of U
multiplied e to the power of
VI now u and v are real numbers so this
equation implies that the absolute value
of Z is equal to e to the^ of U and the
argument of Z is equal to V since the
absolute value of Z and E to the^ of U
are real numbers we can now just apply
the regular logarithm that we always
know to both sides of the equation we
can then bring down the exponent because
U is a real number so the ordinary
natural logarithm of the absolute value
of C is equal to the real number U here
we need another type of notation that we
use a capital letter Ln of X and this
will be the ordinary real natural
logarithm so we can put this all
together to come up with a sensible
definition for the complex logarithm we
wanted to solve the equation Z is equal
to e to the^ of w and W would be equal
to the complex logarithm of
Z so the complex logarithm of Z is equal
to W is equal to U + IV
we showed that in this case U would have
to be equal to the ordinary natural
logarithm of the absolute value of z and
v would have to be the argument of Z so
the definition is the complex logarithm
of Z is equal to the ordinary natural
logarithm of the absolute value of Z
plus I * argument of Z this is a
multivalued result because the argument
of Z can be incremented by 2 pi
multiples if we wanted a single value
result which is often useful this is
what we do when we deal with functions
we want to look whether they're
continuous we can calculate the
derivatives we take the principal value
the complex logarithm of Z is equal to
the ordinary natural logarithm of the
absolute value of Z plus I * r z but
here we limit the argument of Z to be
between pi is less than the argument of
Z is less than or equal to Pi so with
this definition we can
proceed so now we will solve I to ^ of I
so we start out with the definition of
complex exponentiation Z ^ W is equal to
e to ^ W the complex logarithm of Z so
i^ of I is equal to e to power of I
multipli by the complex logarithm of I
so we need to evaluate the complex
logarithm of
I so the complex logarithm of I will be
equal to the ordinary natural logarithm
of the absolute value of I plus I * the
argument of
I recalling that I is equal to e to the
power of ITI piun / 2 + 2 pi k for K
being an integer we can see that the
absolute value of I will be equal to one
so we substitute that in and then the
argument of I will be equal to < / 2 + 2
pi
K so the complex logarithm of I is equal
to the ordinary natural logarithm of 1 +
I * piun / 2 + 2 pi K the ordinary
logarithm of 1 is equal to 0 so the
natural logarithm of I is equal to I *
piun / 2 + 2 pi
K we substitute that into our formula we
now have I multiplied I which is equal
to to i^ 2 i^2 is equal to -1 and this
is exactly the result we want this is
the multivalued result it's equal to e
to power of < / 2 + 2 pi k for K being
an integer these will all be real values
for any integer value of K furthermore
if we limit to the principal value K is
equal to Zer we get I ^ of I is equal to
e to the power of piun / 2 which is
approximately equal to
0.208 and that's the right way to
calculate I to the power of I it does
involve a lot of careful analysis but in
the end this is very important so that
we don't break all the rules of
mathematics and Get Ridiculous results
like 1 is equal to
-1 thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions or we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time